hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown in the wake of
George Floyd's death there is a growing
push from protestors to defund the
police Fox News Sunday host chris
wallace joins the rundown to discuss why
he thinks democrats including
presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee Joe Biden are running as fast as
they can from this movement and explains
why he believes president Trump's push
to hold campaign rallies this summer
could backfire and the debate over
removing Confederate statues is
reigniting amid civil unrest across the
nation Fox News senior judicial analyst
Judge Andrew Napolitano discusses the
legal challenges of taking away these
monuments and also weighs in on
Congress's efforts to reform America's
Police Department's Plus commentary from
hosts a fox across America with Jimmy
fela Jimmy fella the Fox News rundown is
a Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com I'm Stuart Varney I'm Martha
McCallum
i'm jason Chaffetz and this is the Fox
News rundown
[Music]
Friday June 12 2020 I'm Chris foster the
politics of the police defund the police
dismantle the police I think that's a
bridge too far for most Americans and
probably not where politically Jill
Biden and Democrats running for election
that year want to be at Lisa Brady
there's a national outcry over the death
of George Floyd but there might not be a
national answer to what's really a local
question there will probably never be a
national police standard but there will
be a safe floor below which the police
can't go and I'm Jimmy's fella I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
it's not a lot of talk this week about
defunding the police the idea of being
you strip away some of their budget and
responsibilities shifting them to other
areas like social services or housing or
youth programs the supporters say in the
end it would make communities safer
detractors say less policing would make
communities more dangerous and President
Trump says he won't let it happen
there won't be defunding there won't be
dismantling of our police and they're
not going to be any disbanding of our
police our police have been letting us
live in peace and we want to make sure
we don't have any bad actors in there
Joe Biden on Comedy Central's Daily Show
says he's for police reform and using
federal money as incentive we can make
sure that we insist on certain
fundamental changes take place now
including giving making sure there's
sensitivity training making sure that
all of cops fast grievances are she's me
transgressions are all made public
because we can say if you don't we are
not gonna provide the funding that we
provide for you but he came out early
against the idea of actually breaking
police departments up I think that Joe
Biden and mainstream Democrats are doing
everything they can to run away as fast
as they can from defund the police chris
wallace is the host of Fox News Sunday
then author of the new book countdown
1945 the extraordinary story of the
atomic bomb and the 116 days that
changed the world most people myself
included fully understand what that even
means but I think most people when they
dial nine-one-one when there an
emergency want the police to answer and
to help so reform the police that change
some practices like maybe of a National
Registry of bad actors or maybe limit
the the immunity that policemen have
from being sued simple suits but defund
the police dismantle the police I think
that's a bridge too far for most
Americans and probably not where
politically until Biden and Democrats
running for election that here want to
be I guess the idea other than the most
militant calls to just gut police
departments is to just divert some
resources and make them less social
workers and substance abuse counselors
and give some money to that and
have police officers be police officers
but the label certainly doesn't help the
cause no and look there's another
problem because of the economic crisis
that has been occasioned by the kovat 19
you're going to see a lot of cities and
states because Congress is not rushing
to help them with big budget problems
and they their budgets for the police
may already be in trouble so the idea
you're going to cut further is I think
it's gonna create a lot of heartburn
among big city mayors and big city
police chase well Joe Biden is way up
and just poll after poll you've said
several times on this show that he can't
campaign from his basement in Delaware
but mostly so far it's working for him
yeah I think frankly it's working for
him because the president has had a
couple of really bad weeks and I don't
know that he can count on that all the
way from now until November you look at
the polls and the president's approval
rating in Gallup dropped 10 points from
May to June and what I really think it's
about is is that at a time of tremendous
upheaval and division and polarization
and protests the president was seen as a
source of division not a source of unity
and a source of finding the nation's
wounds I mean to have in a single week
that they called out it by everybody
from the Archbishop's of the Episcopal
and Catholic Church in Washington to top
military leaders retired leaders like
general mattis and Admiral Mullen that's
that's tough that's very tough and I
don't think most Americans want to see a
president in that situation he's got to
find a way to make it clear he's not the
president of his base he's the president
of all Americans and I think that's what
that's what a lot of voters are starving
for right now if you look at the polls
during Tuesday's primary in Georgia
there were reports of hours long lines
at some polling places and problems with
bow shortages and voting machines
especially in majority minority
neighborhoods Georgia congressman Doug
Collins he's a Republican fighting Kelly
Lafleur another
looking for her Senate seat in a special
election in November tells FOX counties
the responsibility for putting up and
setting up their elections as it goes
and putting enough from voting machines
having enough train workers and to get
that done it's concerning to me that it
seems like a special Center Met Reuters
we seem to have the same problems over
and over again this was all even though
more people voted by mail this time with
more expected to vote by mail in the
November general election first of all
the kovat 19 crisis we're now saying is
far from over we're seeing spikes in a
lot of states that either never shut
down or open quickly and didn't have
this as strict mitigation measures in
effect so you know it's very possible
maybe not I hope not but it's very
possible that we're going to see serious
virus problems in october/november when
people want to vote and you know it's
it's important for people to vote and
and you certainly don't want people
getting sick or being afraid to vote
because of the fact that that you know
they may get sick from the virus and you
know the idea that if you do go to vote
you can because there's some technical
problem with the machines that the poll
workers don't know what they're doing or
in some cases in Atlanta the poll
workers weren't wearing masks so people
were scared off by them you know it just
seems in the midst of this pandemic that
mail-in voting is is the wise course and
you know despite some statements by the
president you just look at the facts
there is almost no incidents of fraud
and mail and voting it's less than a
thousand cases with more than a billion
votes cast since the year 2000 speaking
of Crona President Trump is there's risk
and reward he's looking forward to
starting rallies again next Friday in
Tulsa Oklahoma maybe he can turn the
energy up but again there's risk and
reward there he gets free media he gets
himself energized but if people start to
get sick that's not great no and and you
know the issue itself have you been
holding mass rallies mass groups even
wearing a mask there's a political
divide there Democrats are
overwhelmingly in favor of
wearing mass social distancing and
Republicans are much more skeptical of
it and you know I just have to say that
that in a in the midst of a pandemic the
idea that wearing mass has become a
political issue is acting for a pretty
good symbol of everything that's wrong
with our body politic today Chris
Wallace the host of Fox News Sunday his
new book out now is countdown 1945 the
extraordinary story of the atomic bomb
in the 116 days that changed the world
thanks Chris thank you Chris this is
Jimmy fella with your Fox News
commentary coming up responding to
overwhelming calls for change after the
death of George Floyd in Minneapolis
President Trump is working on a
four-point plan part of his focus is to
address economic inequality including
health care disparities and minority
communities but he's also calling for
police reform we're working to finalize
an executive order that will encourage
police departments nationwide to meet
the most current professional standards
for the use of force including tactics
for de-escalation it would also
encourage pilot programs that allow
social workers and some law enforcement
officers to work together that's a
different approach than the sweeping
plan from House Democrats who want to
require certain changes and fans certain
tactics like chokeholds and no-knock
warrants the federal government does not
have the ability to prescribe the means
by which local police do their work
Judge Andrew Napolitano was the Fox News
senior judicial analyst there are many
aspects of local and state governance
that the feds cannot directly regulate
when they want to regulate something
that they cannot directly regulate under
the Constitution they usually use the
power of the purse which some people
consider generosity and other people
consider bribery so they will say to the
states here is a hundred million dollars
I'm just using this number as a
hypothetical split it up amongst your
police departments but in route
earn the police departments must promise
no no knock warrants and no choke holds
so that's the way Congress and the
president get around the constitutional
limitations on their ability to regulate
local events now will the states turn
down the money Lisa they never turned
down money they are so care strapped
particularly now when people haven't
been paying sales taxes because they
haven't been going to retail facilities
in order to make purchases that generate
that tax revenue so then this argument
of creating a true national standard for
policing is sounds like a bit of a false
argument I mean could Congress pass
something that gives the federal
government more control over local
police protocols or is just not
constitutional to do that it would
require a constitutional amendment
because the Tenth Amendment reserves to
the states health safety welfare and
morality what we call the police power
so if the Congress wanted to change that
it would have to offer an amendment
which require two-thirds of each house
within three quarters of the state
legislatures that is simply not going to
happen there will probably never be a
national police standard but there will
be a a floor below which the police
can't go theoretically that floor is the
Bill of Rights but we know that's not
the case because the highest right is
the right to live and we all saw George
Floyd's life literally being choked out
of them on video I wanted to ask you if
it's harder to prosecute a police
officer and I don't just mean the issue
of qualified immunity which I would love
for you to explain but also because
prosecutors rely on police for evidence
and testimony in a lot of cases
well prosecutors work hand in hand with
police
so first is it difficult to prosecute a
police officer the answer is yes and
prosecutors who know the cops or work
with the cops should not be prosecuting
those
cops those charges should be transferred
to another city or county depending upon
how they break things up in a given
state a different Authority should
prosecute the cops not one that works
with them and knows them one of the
reasons that it's difficult is because
lawyers are able to persuade judges to
tell juries that cops are given a great
amount of discretion and that they are
only liable for their intentional
behavior so once once you give that
charge to the jury then the jury
invariably says well okay I wouldn't
have done this and I think it was wrong
but it was within his discretion that's
when cops are being prosecuted for
crimes when they are being sued for
civil wrongs as the munis the
Minneapolis Police Department will soon
be sued individual police enjoy what's
called qualified immunity qualified
immunity as an immunity have to qualify
for you qualify for it by being a bona
fide police officer on a bona fide
police mission as a police officer
arresting somebody for passing a phony
twenty dollar bill chokes the guy to
death as absurd as what I'm now about to
say sounds it is the law the police
officer enjoys qualified immunity he
cannot be sued for that I have been
arguing for years since my years on the
bench observing police excesses that
there should be no qualified immunity
that the police should think twice
before they use deadly force
George foot would be alive today as
would many others white and black if
they there was no qualified immunity
because the police would think I'm going
to lose my house I'm gonna lose my
mortgage over this it's not worth it I'm
going to kill this guy person I'm just
going to restrain him but if Congress
wants to
step in and try to get rid of qualified
immunity they can't they have to do the
same thing as the chokeholds and the no
knox pay the states to get rid of it the
reform debate is also turning attention
to the power of police unions that's
were the Minneapolis police chief
midoriya Arredondo started when he
unveiled his own reform plan this week I
am immediately withdrawing from the
contract negotiations with the
Minneapolis Police Federation he's
hoping to make reforms part of the
contract without saying if he thinks
making enough changes would end City
Council efforts to dismantle the police
department but is it legal to do that
anyway Camden New Jersey did it but they
replaced their old Police Department
with a new one and there was a state
takeover first well you know depends on
where you are Minneapolis and New York
have city charters
now a city charter is like the
Constitution it's the document from
which the city's powers come a city
charter is approved by the legislature
and enacted by the voters theoretically
the City Council can't change the city
charter any more than Congress could
change the Constitution most city
charters and again I'm only going to use
Minneapolis in New York because I know
this to be so there are thousands of
cities I obviously haven't seen all of
their charters most City charters
notably Minneapolis in New York require
them to have a police department so
could they fire all the cops and bring
in the state and start all over again
yes they can could they allow the
following to happen which exists in a
city in America when I say what City I
think you'll be surprised I'll hold the
name for the end homeowners in a twenty
or thirty block area voluntarily
contribute to a fund and they pay for
private police the police work for the
homeowners the city police don't even go
in this neighborhood the can if they
want but they don't have to they don't
have to because there's absolutely no
crime no abuse and everybody's happening
now that exists in of all places San
Francisco
and it has existed in San Francisco in
this same neighborhood for a hundred
years most people don't know it mrs.
Pelosi is not happy with it cause she'd
rather have the government provide all
these services I wanted to ask you also
about the renewed fight over Confederate
statues and other memorials they've been
targeted in protests in Virginia now
though there are two lawsuits trying to
block the removal of the robert e lee's
statue
one focusing on the original deed from
1890 that gave virginia control of the
statue that one arguing that the
monument in the area around it was
supposed to be considered perpetually
sacred and there's a second lawsuit
arguing that removing it would violate
the federal trademark a federal landmark
law well those are two worthy lawsuits
now I have a bias here and my biases
that we should not erase history
if these landmarks are on private
property there's nothing that government
can do about it it's freedom of speech
if they're on government property well
then the deed regulates and if they have
been regulates the government's behavior
and in one case you're talking about it
would require an act of the legislature
not just the governor and in one of
those cases there there is no way that
they can as I've read the deed that they
that the state can get out of it other
than buying its way out by paying the
heirs of the deed to surrender their
rights under the deed in the National
landmark case there's no way around it
either and I don't know which way judges
are going to go sometimes judges follow
the laws sometimes they they bow and and
go with the wind but culturally I'm
opposed to this legally the law has to
be followed the US Defense and army
chiefs are ready to consider renaming
some bases named after Confederate
leaders President Trump says he will not
consider that the president will not
stand for that the president will
respect this because these forts and
these names are associated with the
heroes within them not the name on the
court White House spokeswoman Kalam
Akkineni expressing concern that
changing names could imply the
installations themselves are racist but
there is an effort underway in Congress
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi the American
people know these names have to go a
Senate committee already making the
first move military bases are named by
federal legislation so it's not just
somebody jacked up Fort Bragg so that
would require legislation if Congress
passes it and the president vetoes it
they'd have to override his veto and if
they do there's nothing he can do about
it stated differently his status as
commander in chief does not give him Sol
Sol a control over all military property
that's a congressional issue the
president's getting ready to start
holding campaign rallies again he's
talking about maybe next Friday and
Tulsa is the first one does that put his
campaign at risk of lawsuits if someone
gets Cove at 19 at a rally yes yes now
there is the doctrine of assumption of
the risk meaning you are aware of the
risk and you assumed it but assumption
of the risk does not absolve the
defendant of liability it reduces
liability so if you go to one of these
rallies and you get sick and you lose
income as a result of it and you sue and
you win a judgment for your income that
judgment might be reduced by a certain
amount that the jury decides was your
fault for going anyway but it doesn't
block the suit and it doesn't bar the
recovery just reduces the amount what if
they have people make reservations to
attend a rally and have them sign a
waiver with something like that
eliminate the risk of liability probably
not most of those waivers are not worth
the paper that they're written on
because a waiver can't can't change the
law you hold a public gathering you have
a duty to provide
a safe place I mean suppose god forbid
somebody shot up the gathering but you
you had signed a waiver but that's not
going to bar you or your state from
suing the people who failed to provide
security every state in the Union
requires that every public accommodation
which is what the venue would be be
basically safe for the purpose for which
it exists and the owner or occupier of
that public accommodation is not at
liberty to abrogate state law by by
getting somebody to sign a contract it's
a complicated world where you went to
law school I learned them all from you
judge Fox senior judicial analyst Judge
Andrew Napolitano always a pleasure sir
thank you so much for your time all the
best Lisa thank you
[Music]
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Christina
J SEC the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to a Fox News podcasts dot job
subscribe to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts comm and now some good news
with Tonya J powers a 97 year old Hawaii
woman who recently attended a food drive
now has meals on her table and a new
friend Maria Arakaki used her Walker to
get to the event at Aloha Stadium about
a half mile from her house it wasn't an
easy trip I'm gonna try when she got
there she learned she had to have a
vehicle to get the food if you don't go
with a car anything are you sure I'm
going Mike Ganga off is the co-founder
of the show Aloha challenge the group
behind the food drive and told kitv4
Island news what happened a security
guard came up to me and they said that
there was a walker that was at the front
gate and then I said oh we were not
taking walkers but but you know let me
go look anyway I said you know you want
to go in the food drive she said well I
walk I walk far I walk far from my my
house so he helped Maria into his truck
got in line with everyone else and drove
her through the food drive taking her
back home with her new items and even
helped her put them in the refrigerator
I never asked her for docking I never
was happy for what I get Maria says
she'd never been to a food drive and
then it made a big difference
telling Mike it was the most food she'd
had on her table in months I'm getting
these Texas you know from all the
captain's in charge of my shawl or
challenged food drive and I and I'm like
oh my goodness I got a herp and get back
to the food drive and then Maria goes
how about a piece of cake but
instead of rushing back he stayed for
the cake and wound up talking with Maria
for an hour now they've both got a new
friend
Tonya J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
can you fail up what's on your mind
so Warner Brothers announced that Elmer
Fudd is no longer carrying a shotgun in
the newest Bugs Bunny episodes turns out
he doesn't need one because some other
Looney Tunes defunded the police and the
rabbit gets killed by street crime which
is not true but whoever came up with
this idea still needs to be very very
quiet in the next pitch meeting Elmer
Fudd is an absurd cartoon it's pretend
and once you start injecting real world
politics into these scenarios kids lose
the escapism they get from watching them
the producers say they took away his gun
because they're trying to be conscious
of the message they're sending kids come
on man if kids are taking Bugs Bunny
seriously shouldn't we be more concerned
that they'll think rabbits can talk
that's gonna be a seriously
disappointing clash trip to the petting
zoo now I'll admit mr. Fudd wasn't the
most responsible gun owner in the world
the guy spent half his time sticking his
head in the barrel and looking down the
chamber which they do not teach you in
safety school but if we're really gonna
take cartoon seriously didn't we just
violate the man's second Amendment
rights
of course the Elmer Fudd Fiasco wasn't
even the most cartoonishly stupid thing
to happen this week yet this a group of
activists are calling on Nickelodeon to
cancel paw patrol because of the police
dog in the cartoon
lucky for them it's not a drug-sniffing
dog because I'm pretty sure he'd find
some seriously if you think cartoon
police dogs are the problem I do not
want a hit of what you're smoking
because chances are it is way too strong
for me these activists which is slang
for self-hating losers on Twitter claim
chase the dog reinforces the good cop
stereotype at a time when children need
to realize cops do plenty of bad to
which I say you have the right to remain
silent what do you want them to do show
the dog shaking down taxpayers promising
to help poor communities and then doing
nothing he's a dog not a Democrat kids
shouldn't be taught to hate cops and
anyone telling you otherwise is a [ __ ]
and to be clear I'm only calling them
morons because the words I want to use
aren't allowed on the radio look folks I
don't know if you're keeping score at
home but this country is starting to
look like Gotham City before Batman
shows up although what the Ray we're
going bad
man wouldn't bother because it'd accuse
him of being systemic Li biased against
penguins police need our support right
now more than ever and to be clear we
need theirs and in a week we're adults
shows like live PD and cops are getting
yanked off the air the message we've
been sending cops is you're on your own
heaven forbid there should come a day
where they say the same thing to us at
that point we'll need paw Patrol not to
mention Elmer Fudd shotgun
so stop vilifying cops and stop policing
children shows at the end of the day
nobody is getting their values from
watching Warner Brothers cartoons and if
they are we might as well call it a day
because that's all folks listen to Fox
across America with me Jimmy Fowler
weekdays from noon to three on Fox News
Radio com
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes